[Music]
it might come as a surprise to find that
there are a whole bunch of free movies
available to watch on youtube
and it might come as an even bigger
surprise to find that some of them are
actually great
here are a few of the very best
in 1986 john carpenter broke the
cinematic mold with big trouble in
little china
a satirical kung fu movie that sets kurt
russell down in a labyrinthine
chinatown and leads him through an
intriguing plot involving kidnapping
and sorcery unfortunately big trouble in
little china bombed at the box office on
release making back
only around 11.1 million dollars of its
budget which has been estimated at
roughly 20 million dollars
in fact it bombed so badly that it drove
carpenter away from hollywood altogether
but over the years the film's reputation
has increased and it's now considered a
bonafide
cult classic empire magazine rated it
among the top
500 movies of all time and many of its
vocal defenders praise it for its
skewering of stereotypical asian roles
and movies
at the time it was rare for a western
movie even to feature a predominantly
asian cast
as actor james hong has said there will
never be another big trouble in little
china
martial artists the greatest of all
actors writers in that movie
jon gave us all a chance there's never a
bad time to watch the terminator
james cameron's spectacular 1984 sci-fi
action movie about time travel killer
robots and romance
in case you somehow don't know the
premise sarah connor is an ordinary
young woman whose life is suddenly
offended when she turns out to be the
target of a terminator
a cyborg sent from the future to destroy
her before she can birth the son who
will lead humanity against the machines
luckily for her someone else has come
from the future kyle reese
a soldier sent to protect both sarah and
humanity's hope for victory
[Music]
come with me if you want to live
groundbreaking intense
and incredibly fun to boot the
terminator fully deserves the praise
heaped on it by variety who called it
a blazing cinematic comic book full of
virtuoso movie making
terrific momentum solid performances and
a compelling story
and the best part of all once you're
done with this one you'll have a whole
franchise of terminator movies
shows comics and video games to explore
author walter tevis stories are having a
bit of a renaissance these days
mostly thanks to the breakout success of
the wildly successful netflix adaptation
of his novel the queen's gambit
so now's as good a time as any to enjoy
an equally powerful adaptation of one of
his
other stories martin scorsese's the
color of money is a 25 years later
sequel to the hustler with paul newman
reprising his role from the original
newman plays fast eddie a former pool
hall hustler who starts mentoring
vincent
an up-and-coming player there's no way
to do a belated sequel and please
everybody even if you're martin scorsese
but this is still the film that finally
got paul newman his well-deserved best
actor win at the oscars
the cast is the strongest selling point
here sheila benson
writing for the los angeles times
describes the core players as
quote an electrifying unholy trio
throw in a great soundtrack and some
typically brilliant direction from
scorsese and you've got the recipe for a
genuine must watch
let me in is the english language
version of the swedish movie let the
right one in and it actually achieves
the incredibly difficult task of living
up to the original
in fact plenty of critics even argue
that let me in is the better film
horror sight bloody disgusting said
director matt reeves takes a bold and
dangerous step
in basically doing a shot-for-shot
remake of the swedish vampire flick
but finds a way to season it with a
little more emotion and flavor
yes i said it let me in is a better
movie
meanwhile stephen king called it the
best horror film of the decade and
rolling stone's peter travers
said prepare to be wowed it's a
spellbinder
high praise all around so what's it all
about well
let me in is a quiet unsettling study of
the friendship that develops between
owen
a bullied young boy and an otherworldly
young girl named abby things get much
creepier and much darker from there but
it'd be a shame to give away too much
all you need to know is that let me in
is beautifully made
and basically impossible to look away
from and more than justifies all the
praise it attracted from critics
tune into the beginning of an epic
franchise with the original stargate the
1994 sci-fi film starring kurt russell
and james spader
this movie would eventually result in a
sprawling set of tv series which ran for
a combined total of 17 seasons
and a whole host of tie-in novels but it
all started out relatively modestly with
a stand-alone film about an expedition
going through a stargate to a distant
planet discovering aliens who once came
to earth and posed as egyptian gods
spader plays daniel jackson a civilian
linguist and russell
is colonel jack o'neal an air force
officer who is more than okay with this
being a suicide mission
the film got a rocky critical reception
on release
in fact roger ebert hated it so much
that he included it in a 2005 roundup of
his most
hated films but it got a few kinder
notices too
including one review from movie line
which described it as quote
an instant camp classic that is the good
kind of bad
[Music]
how you doing
and of course at the time no one could
see the kind of mark it would eventually
leave on the tv landscape
it really is the little sci-fi film that
could
2008 slumdog millionaire probably needs
no introduction
featuring a star director in danny boyle
and a star
lead in dev patel this movie was a huge
success
first on the festival circuit and then
at the box office it even went on to win
an incredible eight
academy awards including best pitcher
and best director
and of course it has a terrific hook the
film tells the life story of jamal malik
a poor young man who has had an
unexpected and thrilling victory on the
indian version of who wants to be a
millionaire
not missing a single question now he has
to tell his life story to prove he came
by the answers honestly
described by cinema blend as a story of
coincidence luck
and eventually fate slumdog millionaire
isn't so much a strict retelling of
events as it
is as the los angeles times says a
hollywood-style romantic melodrama that
delivers major studio satisfactions in
an ultra modern way
of course the film isn't above criticism
especially in india
a country which some have argued the
movie misrepresents
whether you fall for the magic or just
roll your eyes however slumdog
millionaire is still bound to be a heck
of a conversation starter
the 2004 documentary super size me
chronicles morgan spurlock's ambitious
and
unusual quest to eat nothing but
mcdonald's for every meal for a month in
order to better understand the effects
of fast food on the human body
and it should go without saying but
don't try this at home
still as much as no one wants to see
spurlock vomiting in a parking lot
supersize me is funny riveting and
thought-provoking to boot
it's very easy to take issue with the
validity of spurlock's experiment but
it's hard to argue with the hugely
entertaining film that results
as empire magazine says it's a hugely
enjoyable descent
into epic gluttony it's the thinking
man's jackass
moulin rouge is wonderfully and
unabashedly overblown from its
swoon-worthy romance to its gorgeously
artificial sets
and its exuberant musical numbers the
story follows christian
an aspiring young writer living in a
garrett in paris
when he meets sateen a courtesan and
star performer at the moulin rouge
cabaret
the two fall in love at first sight but
satine needs to be practical
she's promised to the weaselly duke who
has invested heavily in the moulin
rouge's new show which christian is
supposed to write
it's a tangled web of desire secrets
danger heartbreak
and can cans in the movie itself the
artists of the moulin rouge promise that
the new
show will leave its audience dumb with
wonderment and that's exactly the effect
of moulin rouge itself
entertainment weekly sums it up well
saying baslerman's trippy pop culture
pastiche from 2001 is an aesthetically
arresting ode to poetry passion
and elton john if that sounds at all
like something you would like
well then moulin rouge was pretty much
made for you
even if you haven't seen ghost in the
shell you've probably seen ghost in the
shell
this cyberpunk dwar anime centering on a
cyborg government agent
investigating a hacker has exerted a
huge influence on science fiction movies
for example when the wachowskis saw it
their pitch for the matrix finally
jelled
they screened the movie for prospective
producers and announced that they wanted
to do it for real
james cameron who is also one of the
film's many admirers borrowed a little
from it in making avatar while steven
spielberg did the same with ai
artificial intelligence
it really was a perfect storm of
stunning visuals high concept ideas and
futuristic speculation
and as one of the breakout anime movies
in the west it remains a terrific
gateway into the form real rundown gives
it an enthusiastic recommendation saying
as deep as its wonderful animation and
posing lots of philosophical questions
ghost in the shell is a world-class
piece of science fiction that is
uniquely japanese and utterly
irresistible dark
brooding and adult if you've ever found
yourself curious about anime there's no
better place to start
than this 2008's traitor is a gripping
tense thriller that thanks to its
casting of don cheadle and guy pierce
now has the benefit of feeling like a
very weird
iron man 3 reunion the movie dives
straight into a thicket of moral
dilemmas and high-stakes conflicts
cheedle plays samir horn a
sudanese-american man who seems to be
engaging in some murky dealings
so naturally fbi agent roy clayton
suspects him
of terrorism but this is more than a cat
and mouse game it's really a kind of
character study that acts as a vehicle
for cheatle's superb performance
even critics who found the politics
clumsily handled or the twists
implausible agree that it's hard to look
away from the movie star
ao scott of the new york times wrote
cheetos performance gives trader a sense
of ethical gravity and real intrigue
somehow the character retains his
credibility even as the movie perhaps
inevitably trips over some of its own
complexities
and confusions if you can allow for a
slightly messy plot as long as a film is
ambitious enough
and has a damn fine lead performance
then traitor is bound to glue you to
your seat
sometimes cult classics are weird
challenging movies that could never have
found a mainstream audience
and sometimes their adorably silly
rom-com sports movies
take the cutting edge for example the
endearing early 90s movie about a prima
donna figure and the former ice hockey
star who becomes her new skating partner
the movie has plenty of loyal fans who
are more than capable of summing up
its sunny appeal in their review for the
movie decider wrote
at its core the cutting edge is an
endlessly rewatchable immensely
enjoyable film that not only understands
but embraces the fact that rom-coms are
supposed to be fun
and fansighted agreed too saying the
movie is like a fine wine
it has gotten better with age and sure
it's not exactly citizen kane but not
every movie has to be a classic
sometimes all you need is a little
romance and a whole lot of cheese check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you